hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
willkommen zu einem etwas anderen koch
video und zwar hat post bekommen
von marie sie haben hier eine challenge
zugeschickt danke tak li na für diese
nominierung und ich nominiere charlotte
k ihr könnt die kanäle unten in der
infobox mann aus checken aber jetzt will
ich unbedingt wissen was in diesem paket
ist ich hab das vor ein paar tagen
willkommen und dachte ich mache das vor
der kamera auch ich möchte mich nicht
spoilern und dann so tun als ob man hier
nehme ich mir neue ideen vom wochenmarkt
und da müssen wir auch später noch deine
fühle mich gerade wie so ein notar der
so konform dass irgendwas konzert wurde
also es gibt einmal die challenge tiny
cooking sowohl geräte als auch gericht
das heißt sie gerichte müssen klein sei
und die sachen nicht dafür benutzen muss
auch um sein kleines ich habe kein
schnee wie bin kann ich auf jeden fall
so tiny cooking benutzen was die andere
darfst nicht in deiner küche kaum aber
ich koche doch immer in meiner küche ich
liebe meine küche aber ich brauche keine
geräte
ich mein ich kann mich alles mit dem
schneebesen machen wo findet man dinge
im internet brauchen die macht des
internets
wonach suchen kleine geräte wie küche
die eigentlich normal groß und jetzt
klein sind ein küchengerät es gibt auch
schon spiel küchen wo kinder mitspielen
können das wäre doch eigentlich genau
das
ja das ist ein kleiner mixa hatte
funktionierte nicht 2000 jahre später
ich habe jetzt alle geräte bestellt und
wir müssen uns jetzt natürlich noch
gedulden denn die mini geräte müssen
erst bei mir ankommt das heißt wir
können heute noch nicht kochen für euch
das nicht schlimm
ihr seht gleich für mich ich muss warten
die post ist da die post ist da die post
ist da es ist jetzt eine woche später
und ich hoffe dass alle meine tiny
geräte angekommen sind
let's an box des praxis ok ich glaube es
wird alles wäre eine kleine also wenn
davon kleine schüsseln sind
das ist eine kinderküche ja ich habe mir
eine kinderspielecke gekauft an
klein-klein kochlöffel
jetzt brauchen wir natürlich etwas um
nicht in der küche zu kochen weil diese
ganzen dinge also natürlich cool aber
ich darf er nicht in der küche kochen
und dann habe ich es mal gedacht draußen
auf dem grill das vielleicht legen aber
das weiß ich nicht das beiden die romy
komisch deswegen habe ich so camping
dinger gekauft
die werden auch in der zukunft bestimmt
auch benutzt werden
da kann man halt mein garten dann kann
ich mir so eine kleine fahne drauflegen
und braten oder meinen kleinen topf ich
liebe es jetzt kommen wir zu meinem
persönlichen verbindet diese heiko
schütte ähnlich vielleicht aber
natürlich gleich eine teil herzklappen
jahres wir brauchen auch einen tiny ich
könnte man einfach auf festivals
mitnehmen und sicherheit die zahl auf
dem festival machen hatten derbe stufen
ich glaube der hat sogar um luft meint
eine klein ist
was können wir gegen riesengarnelen
teils teil sogar schon sweet chili
chicken irgendwie vielleicht sogar schon
in sweet chili schicken unsere
wirtschaft zum braten für zucker chance
unsere wird passte zum braten für zucker
schon mal unsere wasser für unsere wird
passe zum braten für unsere woche unsere
wird passend zum raten wird sogar schon
zuckerschoten fried chicken kino arata
tui schäuble reagiert sich auf jeden
fall kochen weil damit habe ich im maggi
kochstudio schon gedreht und mitgekocht
gut schmeckt sehr lecker
das will ich auf jeden fall haben
mittagsjournal im mit rind ist darin
schon drin
wie können spaghetti machen ja wir haben
ein kochtopf ein museum
unser hauptspeise wird auf jeden fall
spaghetti sein wenn da jetzt ist der
fleisch drin
tomaten links ein ganzes rennen einfach
das und daraus machen wir uns
tomatensoße für die spaghetti und daraus
machen wir sommerau wir machen sommer
rollen als vorspeise bei getty mit
tomatensoße als nachschub wir machen
sommer rollen als vorspeise spaghetti
mit tomatensoße als nachspeise ja das
erst hier nicht so ich weiß jetzt dass
hermachen
ganz easy und einfach sogar schon
unzählige das ist mein lieblings sehr
schön sogar schon suite kritiken haben
den ofen auch gar nicht wir brauchen
etwas was ihr den ofen pack wir machten
einen schokokuchen einen schokokuchen
mit ice und ein bisschen minze drauf und
so anzugeben weil das sehr schön
also ich nehme die tiny cooking
challenge in nicht meiner küche mit
sommer rollen als vorspeise spaghetti
mit tomatensoße als abgang und
schokokuchen mit eis als bisher drei
gänge machen ich glaube ich habe noch
niemanden den drei gängen gemacht und da
noch in der drei mädchen gut lassen uns
aber von den produkten inspirieren ideen
vom wochenmarkt wir putzen geht erstmal
zum wochenmarkt cooler berliner
wochenmarkt zusammenschnitt in 321
[Musik]
platz muss der wochentag
muss der wochenmarkt nicht dafür dass
berlin da denkst du ist der wochenmarkt
da ist die bei google der wochen und
scheint dieser woche geöffnet ab 16 uhr
geschlossen
wir sind am platz morgen gehe ich gleich
so die einheimischen fragen
entschuldigen sie bitte wo ist der
wochenmarkt gibt schon seit zehn jahren
nicht mehr wollen wir sie so aus es gibt
noch
[Musik]
merck-titel wochen
die avocado und chili keine ahnung 10
und spargel
mehr
jacobi anders
ich habe schon voll zu bekommen und
chinakohl und milz und korea und eine
avocado die sogar für die perfekt an
wir haben jetzt wir brauchen jetzt
eigentlich nur noch die kleinen eier
wachteleier und eiscreme tomatenmark und
staudensellerie den hab ich einfach
nicht gefunden wenn die story dann würde
ich sagen warum immer zu dem supermarkt
unseres vertrauens und wir sehen uns
gleich in der küche wieder die beste
köchin der welt gerufen
bei wenn es heißt kochshow und jetzt
geht's los
ich bleibe natürlich in meinem esstisch
denn ich darf nicht in der küche kochen
danke man hier in dieser stelle und
jetzt würde ich sagen fangen wir mit dem
dessert an
ich fange mit dem schokokuchen an weil
der natürlich auch abkühlen muss und so
und es macht sinn den erstmalig zu haben
einen tiny schokokuchen brauchen wir
natürlich kleine eier
das ist martin herum wo ich vermisse
meine küchenmaschinen und jetzt jetzt
unser halb geschlagenes eiweiß okay
jetzt einen dafür zucker einrühren wir
das einmal miteinander rum margarine
okay wir brauchen jetzt zwei löffel mail
ok jetzt muss aber noch
schokoladenkuchen werden ich mache ein
bisschen rein
so jetzt kommt noch unser eiweiß dazu
dass wir so ein bisschen schaumig
geschlagen haben
jetzt wo ich würde mal sagen das ist ein
stoff einfach da alba oder das würde
glaube ich auch von der menge her passen
ich früh gefahr mir jetzt einmal mit
sally vollbank sli für back trance prey
[Musik]
ok also wir machen auf jeden fall oberen
unter hitze und erstmal so fünf minuten
vor wärme unser offen ist jetzt
vorgewärmt weg kuchen kommt jetzt in dem
julia es schön warm hier drin jetzt
machen wir erstmal ich sag mal auf fünf
wir machen etwas sinnvolles und zwar die
sonderrolle die brauchen auf jeden fall
so ein reispapier dafür für mich wie so
ein kleiner krieger in die schlacht bis
in den tod so wwf habe er hier so eine
vorlage und dann schneit es einfach raus
das sollte doch klappen ohne das ist
zerbricht also es klappt nicht gekriegt
das denn jetzt also das ist doch wohl
absolut scheibe hier mit wasserdampf das
machen wir doch gleich zum schluss erst
mal schneiden wir jetzt unser kleines
böse schneiden wir uns mal was das grüne
scheinheilig oben weg und schneidet das
ist so ein streifen und das funktioniert
richtig gut im kleinen messer
ich bin sowieso ein großer moment so ich
hab riefen hände
nee das ist nicht china coal chicorée
extremes auch die an diesen operation
payback ex gabriel so salat geschnitten
tiny kitchen wird das ausgedacht so als
nächstes brauchen wir koriander
[Musik]
jetzt kommt noch avocado so viel
brauchen wir als nächstes wollen wir
unseren plan beraten und dafür nehmen
wir diese pak choi
was passte wir braten in unserem kleinen
topf das wird schnell heiß ok also
brauchen wirklich nur ein kern kein
tropfen und den pakt schauer ein
mit unserem fanden nach das sieht gut
das sieht richtig gut aus das ist
angebraten
wir brauchen jetzt ein bisschen wasser
auf denn jetzt kommen die reisnudeln die
kleider nicht in teilen sondern nur eben
so
es sieht aus wie ich sie auch mir
irgendwie sind sie aus diesen chemiker
in seinem labor wo gehst du jetzt mal
was passiert mit dem glasnudeln in
braunen wasser sie kommen so und während
die kochen personen mal wenn man mit dem
wasserdampf wegen aufzählt süden kann es
auch für die wissenschaft ich habe jetzt
gar nichts zu schneiden jesus christus
und maria endlich wir haben unser
reispapier und lang genug gedauert jetzt
müssen wir unsere sommer rolle auch okay
wir brauchen erstmal natürlich was von
unserem fahrzeug dann natürlich anna
märchen hokkaido und tatsächlich nur
eine messerspitze knackfrisch ist da
rein das schmeckt uns doch allen gut und
last but not least belassen der trick
ist es zusammen zu halten
[Musik]
voila
[Applaus]
einen sommer holz hier seht ihr meine
teil dieser rolle die vorspeise ist
damit geschafft jetzt müssen wir uns um
den hauptgang kümmern
ich bin so stolz auf sie am ende
probleme wie sie schmeckt jetzt machen
wir unsere hauptspeise mit bolognese
tradizionale mit rind nur ohne reden
also machen wie spaghetti mit
tomatensoße so jetzt nachschneiden
zwiebel ganz klar wirklich klar in ein
indianer kennt keinen schmerz
eine kleine kitchen ist so kein okay das
reicht jetzt kommen wir zu unserer
staunen sellerie meine augen legen immer
noch eine zwiebel jetzt machen wir
wir brauchen ein bisschen olivenöl mit
unserem kleinen löffel ich manchmal ein
heißes
jetzt müssen noch unseren rotwein
portionieren
kann schon mal ein bisschen atmen um die
zwiebel berät die galerie und ein
bisschen mönche und jetzt fahren wir
doch mal schön
es macht schon spaß hinzukommen
ich hab jetzt muss man wach bleiben
[Musik]
zumal markus dabei und das ganze wird
jetzt mit einem guten schuss rotwein
abgelöscht
dass man rotwein abgelöscht operette
oder alkohol fliegt weg dann seht ihr
den eigenheiten es mir in den gewürz
passte hier rein rühren
ja und ich fühle mich schon wieder wegen
kleiner schiene gerne verrät euch an
diese chemischen reaktionen
es sieht aber richtig gut aus
unternehmen so gut mal
[Musik]
wir brauchen jetzt mal für unsere
spaghettis kochen und dafür brauchen wir
wasser ein bisschen salz ins wasser
und wie mache ich nudeln ins wasser
37 sekunden später wasserlos höhere
autos zu glas wasser russ basis das ist
chemie wasser kocht wasser koch nicht
jetzt brauchen wir natürlich über das
handy und ließen unsere nudeln ab jetzt
habt ihr einfach fantastisch somit alles
abgegolten ist dann kommt in eure silvia
schale und da kommt jetzt unseres
obendrauf
und das beste ist auf meinem balkon habe
ich einen kräutergarten und da wächst
gerade ein basilikum industrie zu können
der hauptgang ist angerichtet
hier sogar noch ein kleines glas rotwein
dazu ich bin so unglaublich glücklich
jetzt können wir endlich unsere
schokokuchen okay das ist unser
präsentiert heller und jetzt schneiden
wir stück kuchen ab um diese wenigen was
geworden
okay das ist schon leicht
da ist ein guter schuh das ist unser
stück kuchen ist mit jetzt brauchen wir
ganz feine scheiben von einer mann
ich hasse man gut schneidet so wie cool
das aussieht als krönenden abschluss
gibt es noch eine kugel mango eins oben
drauf so fort
[Musik]
jetzt kommen noch kleine einige
mitspieler und hartz v
[Musik]
mein gott das ist so cool zusammen auch
leute also wenn das meine ich ein foto
werde
unsere leute stellen uns wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt dann
es keine kitchen als vorspeise hätte ich
gerne eine sonderrolle das tagesgericht
also die spaghetti mit tomatensoße zum
hauptgang und als nachtisch später den
schokokuchen mit mangos und mango
stückchen ja super eine kleine portion
hier in dem restaurant die sommer
konnten klein mega lecker vor allem
diese pakte soße das ist kenny chen
das war eine sehr kleine vorspeise der
oma ich nehme schon danke spaghetti mit
tomatensoße da will ich jetzt nicht
ernsthaft daran gedacht okay ich glaube
ich mir gesagt für rotwein das make up
okay die soße schmeckt richtig gut ich
glaube ich habe ein bisschen zu
geschmacksintensiv gemacht so viel
aufwand für so eine kleine portion herz
blutet sehr lecker ich möchte später die
nachspeise haben und danke schön ernst
toller aus warten wir mal in diesem
kleinen dran so kann man nicht wie zu
sagen komm mit mir alles zusammen lange
stücke eis und kuchen
lecker denn bisher ist ganz praktisch
kannst du nicht so viel da vertreten
ich gebe dem restaurant sieben von zehn
michelin sternchen
so funktioniert das system nicht und das
war es auch schon mit dem video dank an
magie für die challenge es hat super
viel spaß gemacht mal so tiny zu kochen
und auf dem wochenmarkt zu fahren und
mal sich da ein bisschen inspirieren zu
lassen
und wie gesagt ich nominiere charlotte
koffer bei ihr vorbei und ansonsten zig
mal die produkte aus idee verrückt markt
also ich bin ein großer fan von diesem
fahrzeug die bolognese hat mich heute
auch sehr überzeugt zeug zeug und dann
würde ich sagen abonniert diesen kanal
und schaut euch andere videos an und
versucht nicht tiny zu kochen weil das
ist wirklich wirklich anstrengt
müde und es war so schnell weg ich habe
hier noch ein bisschen gucken üblich
[Musik]